I was so afraid of my father's
disapproval that I didn't tell him until
I physically left the state think about
that like I wasn't even just one state
over I was like five states over and
then I was like hey by the way I'm going
to California and he was like well let's
come over we'll talk about it and I was
like I'm in Ohio already yeah yeah then
obviously he had a different reaction
right but then after that it was like
what do I have to do now it's like I
gotta sell strangers I told my dad I
didn't want to do what he wanted how
hard could this be it then becomes this
one huge proof point so the bigger that
the dragon is that you have to slay the
more evidence you have that you can say
the next dragon if there's ever been a
good point for why getting over the one
first hard one is so hard is that it
will then give you the reinforcement
that you can do whatever you need to do
next